and finally new rule in the future All
American school kids must be made to
study the
Constitution not ours
Brazil's because plainly that one is
working a lot better than one we have
America ran a very clear scientific
experiment with Brazil recently where we
fa the exact same situation and let's
just say when it comes to democracy
we're the ones who got
waxed Brazil you
know
he needed to stroke the audience more on
that one I
guess so here's what happened in 2020
American incumbent president Donald
Trump a thric married far-right populist
lost his re-election bid and then
embarked on a campaign of outright lies
to convince his supporters the election
had been rigged which resulted in the
siege of the American Capital on January
6th
fast forward almost two years to the Day
January 8th 2023 and jar B balsero
Brazil's thric married far-right
populist incumbent president known as
the Trump of the tropics repeats
the he was repeats the Trump Playbook
exactly after he loses his reelection
bid and thousands of his supporters
storm the Brazilian
Capital both insurrections failed but
here's where we see the difference
between a healthy democracy and one
that's hanging by a thread after January
8th almost all of Brazil turned on the
plotters and made bolsero a pariah but
after January 6th Trump went on to his
Winter Palace in Florida to accept
tributes and replot in opulent Splendor
balsero balsero also went to Florida
where he ate by himself at a
KFC it's a real picture I love you I
love you man
today only 6% of Brazilians say they
support the mob that sacked their
Capital but in America Trump's more
popular than ever and on track to regain
power in Brazil not only has bolsero
been banned from running again anytime
soon but the country United around their
new leader who walked arm in-arm with
Congressional leaders from the left and
right in solidarity against the uprising
arm in- arm in America no arm in arm
arms
yes plenty of
that and threats most Republicans were
literally scared to death to do the
right thing they didn't want to be hung
like Mike Pence or cast raded like
Lindsey
Graham
because the thing is in Brazil their
conservative party is where ours was
during Watergate when Republicans were
willing to throw Nixon under the bus
because they still had ideals higher
than owning the
libs so what changed well part of it
structural their constitution is only 35
years old ORS is 235 and it looks
it we not only still use old timey words
like Jerry mandering we still practice
it the average Republican congressman is
in a safe seat with an electorate he
chose himself and he's only scared of
two things a primary opponent with more
guns on his Christmas
card and getting a nickname from Trump
trump has proven that in America you can
absolutely attempt to coup and at the
very least there's no immediate
repercussions the only way we are
allowed to punish a president is through
impeachment where the jury is the Senate
except California has 68 times the
population of Wyoming and yet we both
get two senators we both get two jurors
in Brazil elections are overseen by a
special elector Al court with judges who
serve two terms we don't have that we
have a partisan Supreme Court whose
terms expire when they
do and who were mostly picked by
presidents who lost the popular vote and
our elections are run by the state so
you got a hodge Pudge of 50 different
election systems with 50 different Rule
books and we're the only nation on Earth
that chooses their ction by way of an
electoral college which is somehow even
worse than regular
college and if all that isn't bad enough
it takes America two months to count and
certify the votes which gives the losers
plenty of time to plot and make Mischief
in
Brazil popular vote always wins
everybody goes to the polls on the same
day and the official commission declares
the winner that night and then everyone
goes outside and flashes their
tits as opposed to here because about 40
years ago we changed television news
Gathering From a public service to a
division of the company that has to make
a profit we let various disturbing
ratings hungry news outlets call the
election and tease out the suspense like
it's the golden Bachelor giving out the
final Rose
it used to be people's opinions were
shaped by the news now the news is
shaped by people's opinions opinions
it's all we hear in the media all day
long when we're not hearing it from our
friends on Facebook and by friends I
mean by friends I mean
Russian and there's one more
thing we're just a shittier people than
we used to be
sorry sorry but we ran the experiment
and we lost in Brazil the polit politics
of grievance has its limits here it
doesn't there are 172 election deniers
currently sitting in Congress but
Republicans only threw out one guy and
ironically he was from
Brazil
so yes our conservatives deserve the
Lion Share of the blame they're the ones
who are sticking with Trump but it's
also not that simple guys it's also the
fact that since Watergate the parties
have flipped personalities Democrats
used to be the party of the working
class and Republicans were the elitist
chardonay sipping the snobs on
The Winning Side of the diploma divide
but that got switched up and people
really hate a snob enough in fact to
vote for Trump
who recently said it's nice to have a
strong man running your country well
many Brazilians remember when it wasn't
they lived under a real dictatorship
less than 40 years ago and so they have
an immunity that we do not it would be
nice if we could get that immunity
without having to get the
disease